-Our next guest is
an Academy Award-nominated
and Emmy Award-winning producer
His latest work,
"The Exorcist: Believer,"
is out now, and his other movie,
"Friday Nights at Freddy's,"
comes to theaters and streaming
on Peacock October 27th.
Let's take a look.
[Buzzes]
-You must be
the new security guard.
-Back in the '80s,
some kids went missing.
That's why the place shut down.
What is she doing here?
-I couldn't find a sitter.
What are you so afraid of?
-Them.
[ Screams ]
-Please welcome back
to the show,
our good friend Jason Blum,
everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back, my friend.
-Thrilled to be here.
"Five Nights at Freddy's"
-Five. What did I say?
-"Friday Nights at Freddy's."
-I said Friday.
It's "Five Nights at Freddy's."
-Everyone says
"Friday Nights at Freddy's."
-Why do we get it wrong?
-"Five Nights at Freddy's."
I don't know.
The sequel is going to be
"Friday Nights at Freddy's."
The guy who created
it just had a heart attack.
-Oh, my God.
"Five Nights at Freddy's."
Alright. That's very --
And this
is based on a video game.
-This is based on a video game
and very, very complicated lore,
and I've been working on it --
I've worked on this movie
longer than anything else
we've ever done.
I've worked on it,
it's been 8 or 9 years
since I first met Scott Cawthon,
who created this,
and he's
a wildly creative genius
and he lives in Texas.
And it was very, very important
to him that it be just so.
We went through
8 directors and 15 scripts,
and I'm very, very proud
we finally got the movie.
-And then I'm out here
just getting the title wrong.
-Yeah, and then you destroyed it
in a heartbeat.
-12 years of your life!
-12 years of my life, ruined.
Now, we did something
interesting on the movie.
Usually, when Hollywood
attacks a video game or a book,
they always say, like,
"We're going to make it
for the fans and we're going to
make it for everybody else."
I probably shouldn't be saying
this on national television,
but I'm just going to go for it.
-That's alright. It's on late.
-Yeah, yeah. True, true. Not
that many people. Okay, fine.
So what what
what Scott wanted to do,
which is an experiment,
we'll see how it works.
I thought it was a very
cool idea, so we said yes,
is we are only
making this for fans
of "Five Nights at Freddy's."
If other people want to see it,
that's fine with us.
We're very happy.
But we're not trying
to expand the audience.
We're trying to keep
the fans thrilled.
And of course,
we won't make everyone happy,
but that's what we did
setting out to make the movie,
which is unusual.
And as I said,
the PR team probably now
is going to come assassinate me,
but that's what we did.
-And do you feel that there is
a groundswell of excitement
from the fans, knowing
that this is the approach?
-Yes, the movie is right now --
I have a little grin on my face,
because the movie
is looking like --
you never know with these
things, as I recently learned,
but it's looking like it
is going to way overperform
what anyone, including myself,
thought it would do.
So knock on wood, that happens.
-Knock on wood. Very exciting.
-So far, so good.
-You are
a horror movie producer.
This should come as no surprise,
you love Halloween.
-I'm a Halloween expert.
-Favorite holiday?
-I'm like Santa for Halloween.
-You are like Santa
for Halloween.
Yes, I've been
at Halloween parties.
You show up, never,
not once without a costume.
-I don't mess around.
-But you also have access
to very good makeup people,
very good costumes.
-No, it's true, I cheat a bit.
-You cheat a bit.
Like, for example,
you and your wife,
your beautiful wife Lauren --
decided to be Stormy Daniels
and Michael Avenatti
a few years ago.
-Yes, we did.
-But you went
a different way with it.
-Yes, we did.
We flipped genders.
-You flipped genders.
-Not bad.
-Come on!
-That's you.
-That was incredible.
-That's incredible.
-People look at -- when
I show that to people,
they really, they look.
It takes like, four seconds
to understand
what's actually happening.
-Yeah.
-But this is actually me,
and this is actually my wife.
-And how uncomfortable
was that evening?
-It was --
It was actually physically,
profoundly uncomfortable
because I had
10 pounds of prosthetics on me.
Is that what you mean?
-Yeah.
-It was very and very
uncomfortable and sweaty,
and I feel terrible for women
in these clothes
that they have to wear, it's
horrible, and in high heels.
-Did not stop you guys
from doing Jared and Ivanka,
though.
-Jared and Ivanka.
-Yeah.
-That was a great one.
Remember when Jared put on
that crazy vest,
you thought he was fighting
the war in Afghanistan?
This was great.
-You produced, "M3GAN,"
a fantastic film.
-Yes, a great film.
-And you decided --
[ Applause ]
-There we go. Give it up.
-Thank you. Thank you.
-You -- The red carpet had
multiple M3GANs.
I don't want to give it away
for the audience.
-Yes, go ahead.
-There's five M3GANS
in this photo.
-Yes, yes.
-Jason is one of the M3GANs.
-This is tricky.
[ Laughter ]
-This might be best of all.
You did
Wicked Witch of the West.
And I mean, this is fantastic.
Look at you.
-You know.
-And then finally,
you let Lauren
be appropriate as Dorothy there.
-Yeah, yeah.
I look like a witch
in real life, so it worked.
-Now, you had a very
interesting producer problem
that you ran into,
because I don't think people
appreciate how important a date
is to when a movie comes out.
So you have this movie,
"The Exorcist,"
you have a date picked out,
a date you're excited about.
-Yes.
-And usually, you know
which movies are coming.
Movies never come
out of nowhere.
-No.
-And then one did.
-This was a terrible tragedy
in the Blum household.
Friday the 13th in October
is the single greatest day
to release a horror movie,
and it only comes around
once every seven years
because there aren't that many.
Friday the 13ths in October,
they're just the once
every seven years.
So we date "The Exorcist" on the
greatest date for horror movies,
that comes around
very infrequently
and about eight weeks ago,
which is the last possible
minute you can change a date,
Taylor Swift drops on my date.
I try and save the day
by "ExorSwift."
I try and make --
I'm hoping, praying,
that this is going to work.
-When you say you tried to make
"ExorSwift" a thing,
here's his efforts, by the way.
-"Exorswift."
Yeah, well,
I didn't try that hard.
I tried, I tried.
Three hours,
three hours after
after I tweet that,
the head of the marketing,
amazing partner Michael Moses,
calls me and says,
"It's not working.
We got to move the movie."
-And so, and then,
this is the follow-up tweet
just a little bit --
"Look what you made me do.
"The Exorcist: Believer"
moves to 10/6.
#TaylorWins.
-Taylor wins.
Yeah, I was trying
to be a nice guy,
because Taylor Swift is
my daughter's favorite singer,
but underneath this tweet there
was rage, rage, rage.
-And it affected
the whole Blum household,
because your wife, Lauren Blum,
who's a fantastic
screenwriter --
-Incredible.
-Her and her partner,
Rebecca Angelo,
wrote a fantastic film
called "Dumb Money."
-Yes, exactly.
-"Dumb Money."
[ Applause ]
And "Dumb Money" is up
against a problem
a lot of these
smaller movies are having.
SAG actors cannot promote
the film.
But she had
to move her date as well.
-Well, so what happened is,
we had to move the movie back,
and it just so happened that
"Dumb Money" was on that date.
So not only did Taylor Swift
destroy my Friday the 13th
and kill this
incredible date I had,
she almost caused me
to get divorced.
-Because you moved
back to 10/6...
-We put on "Dumb Money,"
and my wife said
"You can move anywhere else,
but not there."
I said,
"There's nowhere else to go."
And it was a very tense
24 hours, until my poor wife
had to move her
spectacular movie earlier.
But it's very hard,
these movies,
especially in today's
environment, it's very fragile
and it's very delicate
and moving release dates
is not something you want to do.
So what can I do?
My daughter loves Taylor Swift,
so I feel bad, you know?
And everyone loves Taylor Swift,
so if I said anything bad --
-Taylor Swift
is going to be fine.
loves Taylor Swift.
-I love Taylor Swift!
-I can't get Taylor Swift?
I can't affect her by talking
about her on this show?
-No, I think her movie
is going to do just fine.
-No, that's the problem.
It's going to do amazing.
It's going to do amazing,
and we had to move.
We had to move all our movies.
We almost got divorced.
-Did you think about maybe in
the middle of "The Exorcist"
just adding a scene
of like, Taylor Swift singing?
-I did. Actually, I did.
I said,
"We could either move the date,
we could just add some of
her footage into the movie."
-You got one of your dreams
coming true.
You are going to be
a judge on Shark Tank.
-Oh, yes. This is very
exciting to talk about.
[ Applause ]
-Yeah, tell me more.
-I get asked by people.
This is actually, I'll connect
to your show for a sec.
I get asked by people,
"So did they ask you
to do 'Shark Tank'?"
I don't know about all these
other successful people.
I've never been asked to do --
I begged to be on "Shark Tank"
for 20 years,
just like I begged to be
on your show for 20 years.
I mean, very similar.
-Yeah.
-Anyway, they finally said yes,
and it was great.
And then of course, I get on
"Shark Tank" and I'm doing...
Now everyone says, "So what are
you selling on 'Shark Tank'?"
I'm like, "I'm a Shark,
for God's sake!
I'm not [bleep].
I'm not selling."
They think I'm selling
Blumhouse on "Shark Tank."
For $1 million,
you can have 10% of Blumhouse.
So anyway, I was a shark
on "Shark Tank."
I did it, they taped
two episodes for the day.
You go at 8:00 and you leave
at 8:00 at night or whatever.
It was really fun.
It was really exciting.
And I had a great day. And it
airs -- it airs very soon.
I should know the date when I'm
supposed to be plugging it --
-All you know are
the dates of your movies.
-All I know is the dates
of Taylor Swift, "ExorSwift."
-#ExorSwift.
-It comes out at the end
of this month.
-And were there,
just as a little teaser,
were there anything
you were impressed by?
-There were some things I was --
I've been instructed very --
You can't say
if you invested or not,
so you'll have to watch
the show to find out.
But there were several things
I was very interested in
and it was
it was actually very fun
and they're all really nice,
I had a great time.
And of course,
it was Halloween-themed,
-Ah, so there you go.
-Because I'm
the Santa of Halloween,
so I lent to that,
so it was fun.
-I can't wait to see that.
I can't wait to see
"Five Nights at Freddy's."
-"Five Nights at Freddy's."
-Jason Blum, everybody!
"The Exorcist: Believer."
"Five Nights at Freddy's"
opens October 27th.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."